[Musique]
à voisins le bretonneux ce samedi 24
février une journée dédiée à l'enfance
est organisée mélanie vous abonner
programme oui il s'est même une journée
de spectacles qui est d'ateliers comme
pour les petits comme les grands et
c'est à vivre en famille et ça se passe
à l'espace de colleville
c'est une journée créée par la compagnie
tisseur de son jeu ne compagnie
saint-quentinoise et ça débute dès 10h30
avec un premier spectacle c'est leur
toute dernière création la compagnie l'a
peaufinée toute cette semaine et on y
parle des pierrots et colombines donc
l'idée c'est de prendre ces deux
personnages pierrot et colombine le
pierrot lunaire que tout le monde
connaît un peu l'image de spyro tout
blanc avec cette larme et colombine qui
est un peu son amoureuse son amante et
qu'il ya plein d'histoires de la ssii de
la commedia qui ont été écrits autour
d'eux sont deux personnages très anciens
c'est un spectacle à voir dès 4 ans
c'est un conte musical avec un musicien
qui a composé l'ensemble des musiques du
spectacle qui a aussi été cocodrie peau
produit par la compagnie des arts cesse
et c'est aussi une trentaine de minutes
qui sont accompagnées d'une vidéo est
alors l'après midi il ya des ateliers
donnés aux enfants par les comédiens de
la compagnie des ateliers de musique et
de théâtre
mais les parents ne sont pas oubliés bah
oui quand même ce serait dommage
cependant que les enfants seront en
atelier les parents eux pourront
assister à un film documentaire il a été
réalisé en 1993 par claire simon et la
réalisatrice enregistré des saynètes et
des grandes tragédies qui peuvent se
vivre dans les cours de récréation
et pour clore cette journée un deuxième
spectacle tout comme août le spectacle
s'appelle ruse entre vient de guerre
pour la compagnie c'est leur création
aux 2016 c'est un spectacle de très tôt
qui mêle de la musique du chant de la
danse et aussi du jeu burlesque alors
pour assister leurs à noter c'est 16h30
l'entrée et la participation sont libres
pour les spectacles par contre la
réservation est obligatoire pour les
ateliers de l'après midi merci mélanie
donc
réservations au numéro qui s'affiche en
bas de l'écran merci pour ce rendez vous
aux juniors on passe